el discurso más largo de la historia de
la asamblea fue pronunciado por Fidel
Castro en 1960 aunque los representantes
disponen de 15 minutos castró habló
durante cuatro horas y media denunciando
la hostilidad del gobierno
estadounidense respecto a la isla han
expuesto aquí distintos delegados
entre los distintos problemas que hay
actualmente en el mundo
el problema de Cuba además de los
problemas que hoy preocupan a todo el
mundo
Cuba tiene problemas
que le preocupan a ella la misma semana
Nikita tomó la palabra era la primera
vez que un líder subió chico participaba
en una asamblea general no solo estallo
de rabia y golpeó su mesa con su zapato
pero también habló en favor de la
desmilitarización en el contexto de la
Guerra Fría
déjenos resolver las cuestiones del
desarme General y completo no es
tolerable ningún otro retraso no se
puede tolerar ninguna otra dilación los
pueblos de los estados
independientemente de sus sistemas
sociales esperan que la asamblea general
adopte al menos las decisiones que
responden a las aspiraciones de los
pueblos gracias
en 2006 el jefe de estado venezolano
Hugo Chávez pronunció uno de los
discursos más sarcásticos de la historia
de La Tribuna criticando al presidente
estadounidense George Bush ayer estuvo
el aquí
en este mismo lugar huele a azufre
todavía
desde esta misma Tribuna el señor
presidente de los Estados Unidos a quien
yo llamo el
vino aquí
hablando como dueño del mundo otro
discurso sobresaliente fue el que
pronunció el líder libro garafi en 2009
condenando el funcionamiento del Consejo
de Seguridad de la ONU
ahora el Consejo de Seguridad es un
feudalismo de seguridad un feudalismo
político para los que tienen puestos
permanentes se utiliza contra nosotros
no debería llamarse Consejo de Seguridad
debería llamarse consejo del terror
todos ustedes están dormidos todos
ustedes están cansados tampoco se puede
olvidar la intervención del Primer
Ministro israelí benjahu en 2012 que se
ayudó de un boceto muy simplificado para
denunciar el programa nuclear de Irán un
tema que 10 años después sigue en el
centro de las conversaciones